[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
on est ravi de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle émission on va vous parler de
sujets passionnants mais pas du
remaniement parce qu'on va être franc
nous n'avons pas la composition du
prochain gouvernement et donc nous avons
préféré nous abstenir
mais regardez les quatre sujets quand
vous a préparé regardez les en images
ils sont passionnants cette nuit dans
une indifférence à peu près totale
l'assemblée nationale a adopté une
proposition de loi sur les faits que
news est-ce que c'est un progrès ou est
ce que c'est un peu liberticide sur les
bords eh bien vous ne vous nous donnerez
votre point de vue aujourd'hui le haut
commissaire à la réforme des retraites
jean paul delevoye a reçu les syndicats
pour leur parler de la grande réforme
des retraites du quinquennat il va sans
doute falloir travailler plus longtemps
mais est ce que c'est forcément un drame
on en parlera on parlera aussi du sommet
de la francophonie de la francophonie ça
se passe à erevan ça commence demain le
président de la république s'est envolée
pour la capitale de l'arménie
la francophonie est ce que ça sert
encore à quelque chose aujourd'hui on va
s'interroger sur ce sujet et puis on
vous parlera de ce scandale révélé par
le canard enchaîné le patron de force
ouvrière pascal pavageau en tout cas son
entourage a fait des fiches assez
renseignée et pas forcément aimable sur
tous les cadres dirigeants du syndicat
est-ce qu'il doit démissionner ou est-ce
qu'il peut rester en place vous nous
donnerez votre point de vue je vous
présente tout de suite les quatre
invités qui ont accepté d'être là
aujourd'hui
bonjour leila aichi vous êtes avocate
femme politique vous avez été sénatrice
de paris avec l'étiquette europe
écologie les verts vous êtes président
d'association de l'association huit
impacts qui se mobilisent pour l'impact
du réchauffement climatique
damien le guay et la bonsoir vous êtes
philosophe essayiste maître de
conférences h c'est votre dernier livre
la guerre civile qui vient est déjà là a
été publié aux éditions du cerf bonsoir
frédéric saint clair vous êtes analyste
politique vous avez été un collaborateur
de dominique de villepin quand il était
premier ministre
vous collaborez régulièrement au figaro
aux écossais d'ailleurs je crois est
votre dernier livre la droite face à
l'islam a été publié aux éditions
salvator
puis vincent hugeux elle a aussi bon
soit rasoir vous accueillir vous êtes
grand reporter au service international
de l'express ou fait notamment un très
grand spécialiste de l'afrique
votre dernier livre est une biographie
de kadhafi a été publié chez perrin et
vous enseigner à l'école supérieure de
journalisme et à sciences po
on commence par ce premier sujet la loi
sur les faits que news a été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale je vous en
rappelle le principe
le juge des référés pourra être saisie
d'informations manifestement fausse
diffusé pendant les campagnes
électorales et le juge pourra très vite
intervenir par exemple pour des
références et les sites internet qui
diffusent ce genre d'image est ce que
tout ça est une bonne idée
ou est-ce que c'est dangereux il y en a
qui tu pas vraiment d'accord avec cette
loi et c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est jean luc mélenchon pour lui c'est
carrément dangereux regardez il en a
parlé
cette nuit à l'assemblée c'est une très
mauvaise plaisanterie
le magistrat évalue seule la qualité de
fausses informations ils décident en 48
heures il n'y a pas de possibilité
d'appel
des fillon terrifiante un type tout seul
ou une femme tout seul dfid et on ne
peut même pas faire appel
alors on se souvient que c'est le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui avait voulu cette loi
notamment après les fausses nouvelles
qui avaient couru pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'est elle qui par
exemple lui
donnait des comptes bancaires à
l'étranger ce qui s'est révélé être
complètement faux vincent jeu est ce que
vous partagez le l'inquiétude de jean
luc mélenchon est ce qu'elle est
dangereuse cette loi non je n'ai pas son
sens aigu de l'hyperbole donc je m'en
tiens à ce constat élémentaires qui est
que vouloir légiférer sur ce qui porte
sur la désinformation d'information
revient à peu près à épousseter le
désert du sahara ou à vider l'océan avec
un dé à coudre
pourquoi parce que vous vous heurtez à
deux évidences 1
le degré de sophistication des
machineries d'intox est telle
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une oie avec
les limites qui ont été énoncées au
d'autres sur lesquelles on viendra sans
doute qui va y mettre un terme
et puis il ya quand même un autre
phénomène que je trouve assez assez
troublant la matière c'est que s'ils
voulaient quand on regarde le texte en
question on s'aperçoit que légiférer
c'est aussi alimenter les thèses
complotistes dire que vous allez
évidemment donné du carburant à ceux qui
disent on ou bayonne on nous empêche
voyez ça c'est l'establishment et
certains ont fait taire parce qu'on dit
la vérité alors liberticide je reviens
sur ce mot qui est très en vogue
vous savez à la différence notable des
piles vander la liberté de la presse ne
s'use que si l'on ne s'en sert pas c'est
à dire que c'est parce que des
journalistes et des citoyens seront
exigeants en la matière que l'on n'aura
pas ce qui se joue en ce moment au
brésil
il est utile d'aller jeter un oeil là
bas où le grand quotidien globo a relevé
une cinquantaine de grossières fait nous
y paraît qu'il faut dire un fox en bon
français alors que c'est déjà là aussi
un anglicisme mais passons avec des
éléments aussi grotesques mais qui ont
pesé sur le succès électoral en tout cas
premier de sur de gea bel subaru que le
pt le parti des travailleurs donc dont
le candidat fernando haddad dans quelque
sorte la doublure un peu pâlichonne
lula incarcéré et bien souhaite
enseigner un kit gay on a vu ça ailleurs
on a entendu aussi à l'école primaire
diffuser des tétines en forme de pénis
ou données la gestion des enfants de
plus de cinq ans pour le choix de leur
genre sexuel à l'état et tout ça ça
passe quelques commentaires de
d'internautes sur twitter ou sur
lefigaro.fr
selon céline de chansonnettes cet
internaute nous dit c'est une volonté de
museler la presse
n'importe quel candidat pourra faire
n'importe quoi il criera à la fec news
dès que son cas sera cité on vous a
interrogé d'ailleurs sur twitter vous
pouvez vous pouvez voter pour savoir si
selon vous la loi contre l'effectuent
osé protectrice ou liberticide et bien
pour l'instant c'est 50-50 donc d'où
l'intérêt de ce débat pour vous aider à
vous faire une opinion
si vous n'avez pas encore de point de
vue bien arrêtée sur ce sujet est mort
de chez nous dit le but de cette loi et
d'empêcher toute critique efficace du
gouvernement par les médias alternatifs
et les réseaux sociaux fait avec cinq là
votre point de vue sur ce sujet alors
une fois n'est pas coutume mais
l'intellectuel conservateur que je suis
est d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon il
y as au mieux une inutilité parce qu'un
manque de moyens pour qu'une telle loi
si elle était pilotée par quelqu'un de
réellement intelligent soit efficace
mais en plus de ça je pense que les
effets pervers d'une loi comme celle là
où on confond les fins et les moyens
finalement va nous peut amener à une
cacophonie un embourbement de la justice
un poids beaucoup trop importants
accordés aux juges dans une campagne
électorale parce que c'est cette période
là de la vie politique est ciblé en
priorité et on a vu que le sur pouvoir
des juges en campagne électorale pouvait
détruire un candidat on attend encore le
jugement sur françois fillon rappelant
le maquereau et en examen effondrée à
30% d'opinions positives et on est
encore en train d'attendre de savoir ce
qu'il en est des deux costumes de
monsieur françois fillon
ce n'est pas bouclé bon donc je dis
juste que les campagnes électorales
j'aimerais plutôt qu'on ait une sorte de
suspension du jugement moral parce que
finalement c'est bien de ça dont on
parle quand on parle de fenioux ce qu'il
décide de ce qui est vrai de ce qui est
faux dans l'absolu monsieur mélenchon se
soulève un point important en 48 heures
on doit se prononcer via le fait en lui
même n'est jamais incriminant tiens il
ya derrière autre chose il ya il ya une
façon de le présenter il ya un ensemble
d'éléments concordants discordantes
importe mais concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on a pour juger et ensuite comment on
va faire pour museler
vous l'avez dit en introduction bien
évidemment que les réseaux sociaux vont
se mobiliser en modifiant plus ou moins
la nouvelle contournant les
interdictions évidemment mettra ici je
me tourne vers l'avocate est ce qu'on a
raison de se méfier des juges
est-ce qu'on a raison d'une manière
générale à un pouvoir il faut toujours
un contre-pouvoir effectivement je
considère que cette loi n'a
objectivement pas beaucoup d'utilité eu
égard à la technicité des process pour
les faits que nous et ça pose également
un autre problème je suis pas forcément
sur la ligne politique de jean luc
mélenchon mais je rejoins un peu son
inquiétude sur le côté liberticide
cette possibilité est réelle mais
au-delà de ça il y à la question de
comment le juge va interpréter la fecq
news alors je je je peux vous assurer
que pour les magistrats et les avocats
d'une manière générale et les magistrats
l'interprétation est rendu une décision
ça peut paraître simple sur le pâté
qu'est ce qu'une fait que nous mais de
l'appliquer juridiquement aucune
sanction d'un terminera que c'est là le
délit est constitué aussi on reconnaît
effectivement la fecq nous mais après
une élaboration et un process d'analysé
très compliqué d'un point de vue
juridique
et comme le focus encore une fois c'est
souvent le problème dans notre pays
c'est qu'on veut légiférer sur une
réaction est là typiquement c'est la loi
du président de la république et ont été
victimes de faits que nous considère que
c'est une urgence absolue
il faut faire effectivement attention
hein pas tomber dans la diffamation on
doit toujours trouver un juste équilibre
en ce qui concerne cette loi je suis
toujours plus ou moins inquiète quand
d'une manière générale de politique
l'exécutif le législatif commence à
s'occuper de la liberté de la presse et
de l'histoire d'une manière générale oui
parce qu'il ya une vraie part de
subjectivité chez le juge ça je peux en
témoigner comme directeur de journal
il ya déjà des propos qui sont
considérés alors je prends par exemple
des propos qui ont été tenus par eric
zemmour en l'occurence n'était pas dans
le figaro magazine mais qui en première
instance ont été considérés comme de
l'incitation à la haine raciale et en
appel le juge a dit bah non c'est sa
liberté d'expression de le dire donc
donc c'est pas facile
d'ailleurs une fausse nouvelle c'est pas
toujours ce qu'on croit je vais vous
passez la parole damien le guay mais
écoutez d'abord un autre député de la
france insoumise mobiliser contre cette
loi
c'est alexis corbière lui dit ben la
fausse nouvelle
il y en a certaines qui sont pas dénoncé
alors que pourtant elles sont réelles et
y pense très fort à emmanuel macron
figurez vous regardez le phénomène
majeur en matière de presse lors
l'élection présidentielle c'est pas ce
que spoutnik de manière confidentielle a
dit emmanuel macron c'est ce que 100% et
mais n'y en aurait pas tes d'emmanuel
macron qu'il était le seul candidat en
capacité batouala mme le pen qu'il était
le seul candidat à pouvoir apporter de
réponse en ce pays
damien le guay évidemment à lui aurait
préféré que ce soit que jean luc
mélenchon et était l'homme quand
capacité de faire battre madame le pen
mais là on est sûr de l'analyse
politique
mais quand même quand par exemple on dit
jean luc mélenchon et des comptes
offshore à l'étranger que lui dément
balla et ce n'est pas illogique que le
juge puisse dire à arrêter c'est pas
vrai vous n'avez pas le droit de dire ça
ce qui trait sur très compliqué c'est de
savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui est faux
la partie moment gagné le philosophe qui
commence invité pour ça que c'est
pourquoi je me permets comme un peu de
hauteur
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est ce qui est
faux nous savons tous quand on a fait un
peu d'histoire de l'office de filles ou
même quand on a regardé un tout petit
peu ce que disait vraiment ont déjà d'en
avant la guerre que tout récit
historique est un mélange entre des
réalités que l'on connaît et puis une
interprétation une conception des choses
donc les deux vont toujours ensemble il
ya toujours un récit et des faits donc à
partir de quel moment est ce que on peut
déterminer qu'une information est fausse
soit effectivement elle n'a jamais été
prononcé de façon d'une autre soit elle
est pour partie vrai pour part
il faut un peu interpréter une façon
d'une autre et donc très difficilement
son multi de dire ce qu'il en est
premier premiers points 2e point quand
on voit effectivement ce qui s'est passé
pour l'élection de trump trump tous les
médias étaient contre lui tous les
médias n'ont pas arrêté en permanence
tant dans sa compagne de dire que ceci
était faut que ceux-ci étaient faut que
ceux-ci étaient faux et ça n'a pas
empêché malgré ça d'être élu donc quelle
est la capacité qu'ont les électeurs de
pouvoir accepter cette part de fo de
vraisemblable de deux condamnations par
les juges etc pour élire quelqu'un et
puis troisième chose qui me paraît plus
important c'est que si notre démocratie
souffrait de cela ça serait parfait
le vrai problème c'est que les journaux
ne sont pas crédibles
les français le disent les français le
répète les hommes politiques ne sont pas
crédibles
la parole publique n'est pas entendue
elle n'est pas crédible donc le premier
travail me semble t-il à faire si on
veut redonner du sens à la politique et
aux informations et à ce que peuvent
dire les journaux c'est d'une façon
d'une autre de rendre crédible tout cela
et pourquoi est ce que les journaux ne
sont pas crédibles
parce que pour partie sous ils répètent
tous à la même chose et donc il ya
quelque chose qui effectivement à
l'horizon à un bruit unique qui condamne
et effectivement parler d'eric zemmour
qui condamne michel onfray qui condamne
ceux qui disent autre chose
donc la question c'est plus l'écosystème
me semble t'il que cet élément
particulier et puis dans ce que disait
dans ce que disait au moment où
effectivement elle était auditionné
maladie scène elle assistait beaucoup et
sa ministre de la culture
mais la culture aux anciens proches qui
soutient ce projet et au moment où elle
annonce effectivement que les étaient
ses intentions est ce qu'elle voulait
faire elle a beaucoup insisté sur
l'éducation il faut effectivement que
dans les classes ou d'une façon générale
l'éducation à la
l'information numérique et ça c'est une
excellente idée quoi la machine j'ai
alors les journaux sont ils crédibles
alors maintenant si tu savais qu'on peut
être on peut parfaitement être crédible
sans être cru et c'est un peu la
tragédie de nombreux médias honorable
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que pour des
raisons qui tiennent aussi aux erreurs
qui ont été commises par les
journalistes et par les directeurs
rédaction les médias et les acteurs des
médias sont assimilés à une élite
lointaine mais présentait parisienne
donc vous pouvez avoir un article qui
est inattaquable factuellement il
n'empêche que si vous conduisez une
enquête relativement sérieuse en termes
de critères scientifiques vous aurez une
proportion notable de lecteurs qu'ils
considéreront que ceci est biaisé fautes
et les guides etc
je vois dans le texte tel qu'il a été
voté quasiment en catimini
cette nuit quand même d'autres zones
d'ombré d'autres angles morts je voulais
en relever est juste très rapidement
quelques-uns le fameux en période
électorale
moi me trouble beaucoup parce que vous
dire que une heure suffit à séparer le
vis de la vertu les trois mois etc
je ne comprends pas ce qui se joue par
rapport à la construction par rapport à
la déconstruction d'un personnage va
très au delà ou très en deçà des trois
mois donc je ne comprends pas très bien
cette clause temporel le concept ça a
été dit mais manifestement fausse moi
c'est quelque chose qui me laisse
absolument pompeux aloir parce qu'il y
avait eu une fausseté qu'il serait
manifeste une qui serait retord une qui
serait partiel une qui serait subtil une
qui serait grossière je crois que il ne
peut pas y avoir d'instrument de mesure
objective deux objectifs de ce qui est
malheureux que tu auras troisième d'un
troisième point qui vous gêne si oui
d'accord je termine là dessus on parle
de l'intérieur l'intervention du juge
qu'ils seraient encadrés mais encadré
comment et par qui et en vertu de quel
texte est quelle philosophie de
l'information gier l'intention est sans
doute louable
quel que soit le vrai moteur de ce
projet porté par la macro ni mais il y a
tellement de faille à la fois théorique
et pratique que je pense que c'est un
bel exercice inutile et bien merci
beaucoup je crois qu'il ya l'unanimité
sur ce plateau c'est assez rare et
j'allais dire tant pis on va te décides
dernier mot asim sur les réseaux sociaux
qui nous dit à mon avis avec plein de
sagesse de toute façon une fois que la
rumeur est lancée elle est inarrêtable
non c'est une belle conclusion
on passe à un autre sujet d'actualité du
jour c'est donc la réforme des retraites
ça l'un des grands projets du
quinquennat emmanuel macron l'a dit il
voudrait unifier les régimes de retraite
avec un système unique par points
le responsable de ce dossier jean paul
delevoye a reçu les syndicats
aujourd'hui pour expliquer un petit peu
ce qu'ils voulaient faire l'accueil on
va dire que il est il est assez inégal
du côté des syndicats et coûté deux
points de vue d'abord celui de pascal
pavageau
le patron de force ouvrière qui est
assez contre le projet est celui de
laurent berger le patron de la cfdt qui
lui est plutôt pour pour nous c'est une
réforme qui va détruire les quarante
deux régimes existants pour avoir un
régime unique ou universel par points
et ça nous n'y sommes pas favorables on
a une première phase qui s'achève
maintenant il faut rentrer dans le fond
du sujet et savoir comment tout ça va
être mis en musique je crois qu'on peut
faire une réforme où il ya moins de peur
donc et pas de perdant par rapport à la
situation actuelle
alors il ya plusieurs éléments danser
dans ce projet il ya d'abord ce dont on
parle c'est à dire les points on va y
revenir un peu un peu tout à l'heure et
puis il ya aussi l'idée que jean paul
delevoye a avancé et puis maintenant il
rétropédale un peu que de toute façon il
faudrait repousser l'âge de la retraite
pas parce qu'on vit de plus en plus
vieux et qui a de moins en moins
d'actifs
les syndicats sont assez contre le
report de l'âge de la retraite
et pourtant est ce que c'est vraiment si
grave que ça il a ici non en fait
effectivement il faut prendre en
considération enfin une réalité nouvier
nous vivons plus longtemps et c'est tant
mieux
c'est un sujet qui qui est extrêmement
important pour le devenir de notre
société maintenance est au delà de la
proposition de cette réforme à
proprement parler se pose la question de
sa mise en place en été et le fait de
biaiser notamment le parlement pour la
fameuse retraite pivot comme tout pivot
ses invocations à bouger peut susciter
encore une fois des réactions il s'agit
de rassembler sur un sujet complexe et
compliqué pour notre société maintenant
il ya une réalité que l'ensemble de la
société doit prendre en compte
effectivement on vit plus longtemps et
ça pose des questions de comptabilité
publique signée réattu ou de toute façon
il y aura des perdants et les
fonctionnaires qui ont des régimes
spéciaux par exemple là ils vont s'en
sortir un peu c'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut nécessairement avoir un consensus
c'est pas simple mais évidemment il y
aura des perdants il y aura des gagnants
mais c'est pas comme ça ils n'ont plus
qu'il faut raisonner il faudrait arrêter
le problème que nous avons globalement
dans notre pays c'est de toujours
opposée en fait une catégorie à une
autre
donc avec la réforme de retraites
significativement on oppose encore les
retraités à la jeunesse c'est un danger
sur lequel on a tendance à glisser de
manière assez assez
assez fréquentes et c'est dommage
maintenant il ya une réalité je pense
qu'effectivement il faut réfléchir et
avancer sur la question de la retraite
il ya des ruptures d'égalité entre les
différents entre les différents les
différents régimes de musique et
d'unifier tous ça c'est pas simple mais
c'est pas un sujet simple mais il faut
impérativement le porter en ayant le
maximum de consensus vous a posé la
question sur sur lefigaro.fr c'est même
la question du jour faut-il repousser
l'âge de la retraite l'âge légal
aujourd'hui à 62 ans pour autant que
vous ayez tous vos trimestres
bah écoutez c'est assez partagés 1 55%
oui il ya un peu moins de 18 mille
votants
frédéric sinclair est qu'il faut
repousser l'âge de la retraite si on n'a
pas un métier qui est fatiguant
physiquement
en quoi est-ce que c'est forcément une
défaite de travailler plus longtemps
à vrai dire pour les gens qui ont des
métiers qui ne sont pas fatiguant et qui
ne sont pas mis fatiguant physiquement
ni fatigué psychologiquement parce qu'il
ya parfois prenons par exemple les
professeurs
il arrive à bout de souffle parfois en
fin de carrière j'ai enseigné dans des
zones qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui et
je peux vous assurer qu'ils attendaient
il en est vraiment d'être d'être libéré
ça parce que nerveusement ce n'était
plus possible mais les personnes ne
partent pas continue de travailler
d'être actif et de trouver des moyens
justement pour pour continuer d'exister
et la regarder des intellectuels ils ont
largement dépassé les 62 ans il occupa
encore les plateaux de télé radio les
chairs extra donc j'allais dire les les
jeunes ont peut-être même envie qui
partent à la retraite
non je pense que le vrai problème il est
il est beaucoup plus à la fois beaucoup
plus profond est beaucoup plus
pragmatique l'aspect profond c'est que
nous sommes entrés dans une société du
loisir et downeast dans les années 50 où
on a cru qu'un nouveau monde était
possible et où on a globalement vu
s'incarner grâce au capitalisme
la société qui avait été rêvé pendant le
19e siècle et le 18e d'ailleurs où le
paradis ayant disparu on allait pouvoir
leur créer sur terre qu'en travaillant
possible oui et en profitant le plus
largement possible des bienfaits que le
confort matériel peut apporter dans tout
ça c'est qu'on consent quand on est
travailleur à à donner de son temps et
de son énergie c'est normal de se dire
que puisqu'on vit plus longtemps on va
pouvoir le récupérer là ce qu'on est en
train de dire aux gens c'est que le
métier au quotidien devient de plus en
plus du dur pardon et que le temps
qu'ils vont pouvoir avoir de disponible
en train de se réduire comme peau de
chagrin
comment vous voulez que les gens
acceptent avec sympathie ce genre de
déclarations damien le guay cc il ya
forcément un mauvais accueil d'une
mesure comme celle là parce que le
travail ça reste une aliénation dans
l'inconscient collectif alors le bon
accueil simek si j'ai bien compris c'est
que pour la première fois
si j'ai bien compris ce dont il s'agit
pour la première fois on ferait une
réforme systémique du système dans sa
globalité et non pas une réforme des
paramètres des 2/3 permettre qu'on
change depuis deux ans 88 à chaque fois
donc ça veut bien dire qu'il y aurait
quelque chose
si j'ai bien compris et si effectivement
il y arrive qui serait pérenne donc ce
serait la dernière
des réformes qui permettrait
effectivement d'unifier de faire en
sorte que qu'il n'y est plus et 42
régime et que l'on puisse arriver une
situation ça c'est plutôt positif
ça c'est plutôt positif voilà session
pour une fois si on arrive effectivement
à s'attaquer à cette question là et non
pas à considérer que les réformes que
l'on fait qu'ils sont à chaque fois
douloureuses seront refaites deux ans
après ou trois ans après ce qui laisse à
penser comme que soit ya un problème de
prévisions soient effectivement deux
hommes politiques ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux qu'ils font avaler au
fur et à mesure aux français mais ceci
dit le problème c'est que les français
sont relativement là c'est de cela parce
que ça fait effectivement depuis 88
confédérés forme tous les deux ans aux 3
ans sur ce même sujet et la deuxième
chose c'est que les français ont peur
parce que quand on les interroge 8,8
français u18 actifs sur dix disent
qu'ils ne vont pas retrouver au moment
de la retraite
un niveau de vie suffisant à la hauteur
de ce qu'ils devraient avoir donc le
sentiment global
c'est un sentiment d'appauvrissement
collectif que quelque chose sera moins
bien demain qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
et pareil pour les générations d'avant
donc le problème c'est de soi ya deux
approches possibles sont nés comme ce
que fait macron entouré de gens plus
intelligents les uns que les autres
on a une approche économistes de
gestionnaires ont dit voilà on va
trouver le bon format lé les bons
paramètres et puis on repart jusqu'à la
fin et sa trame en soit on est dans un
problème national
c'est à dire qui suppose de faire appel
à la nation à la solidarité nationale et
donc pour cela il faut effectivement
faire en sorte de pouvoir entendre ce
que dit la nation surtout dans l'ordre
c'est inquiétant cendres et un prix les
inquiéter exactement alors justement
pardon parce qu'on va nourrir cette
inquiétude figurez vous
ce projet de retraite par points
françois fillon on avait parlé c'était
lors d'un grand oral devant des patrons
il ya deux ans et lui il est plutôt pour
la retraite par points mais la raison
pour laquelle il est pour vous allez
voir c'est peut-être un peu inquiétant
le système de retraite par mois j'y suis
favorable mais il faut pas faire croire
aux français que ça va régler le
problème des retraites
le système par points en réalité ça
permet une chose qu'aucun homme
politique n'a vous ça permet de baisser
chaque année le montant des points la
valeur des points et donc de diminuer le
niveau des pensions
vincent j'étais un petit peu ça le
problème c'est à quoi les français se
disent tous
on nous annonce une réforme pour qu'il
soit égalitaire mais en fait on veut
détériorer les conditions de notre
retraite c'est assez cocasse c'est que
l'argument de françois fillon je les
entends du voilà quelques heures dans la
bouche d'une délégué de la cgt
il ya là un apparentement tout à fait
inattendue écoutez là je suis à deux
doigts de dégainer mon joker parce que
je n'ai ni compétence ni expertise en
matière sociale j'ai simplement une
remarque et ce sera ma seule
contribution à ce stade c'est que autant
on peut trouver exotiques et
anachronique le fait d'avoir 42 régimes
de retraite en france aujourd'hui
autant donc le l'idéal d'harmonisation
me paraît fils de flic mans recevable
autant l'uniformisation serait à mon
sens indéfendable pourquoi parce qu'il
faut absolument qu'il y ait une prise en
compte de facteurs exogènes dont
certains étaient mentionnés exposition
au stress
exposition aux produits toxiques
carrière fracturé par des périodes de
chômage subit obligations familiales de
venir au secours d'un enfant d'un
conjoint d'un parent malade
donc on ne peut pas dire ratiboiser la
règle et l'imposer à tous dans les mêmes
circonstances
il faut garder cette marge de manoeuvre
là quelques commentaires sur internet
claude qui nous dit chiche monsieur le
président enfin une vraie réforme
irez-vous jusqu'au bout au point
d'interrogation puis da finale qui nous
dit la population vieillissante et
l'augmentation de l'épée rente de
l'espérance de vie impose le fait que
l'on doive repousser l'âge de départ à
la retraite
leila ici il peut y avoir un consensus
sur ce sujet on sent déjà les syndicats
qui sont tout est opposé ils sont très
représentés chez les fonctionnaires qui
a priori même si on va vite en disant ça
sera un peu plus favorisés que le privé
j'espère un consensus maintenant il faut
être à peu près lucide un évidement tous
ceux qui ont à perdre on parle forcément
envie d'avoir l'impression que leur
niveau de vie
b sera dans quelques années la question
étant que c'est un sujet effectivement
éminemment compliquée et complexe pour
plusieurs raisons la première étant
c'est qu'effectivement on a déjà
beaucoup de régimes différents qu'il
faut effectivement prendre en compte la
pénibilité au travail et qu'en même
temps il ya aussi une réalité économique
à laquelle il faut faire face on vit
plus longtemps on doit aussi dans
certains cas pour certains métiers
pouvoir travailler un peu plus longtemps
pour les travées le travail qui est
pénible évidemment on doit le prendre en
considération en tout état de cause je
j'imagine que la situation va être va
être compliqué même si j'espère un
consensus
est ce que je trouve dommageable et
encore une fois c'est qu'on est toujours
en incapacité d'avancer collectivement
pour trouver une solution acceptable par
tous on est toujours en train d'opposer
les uns aux autres on attend toujours de
se retrouver face au mur avant de
pouvoir de pouvoir trouver une solution
au problème et ça ralentit notre ça
ralentit d'une manière générale notre
notre économie se donne pas toujours une
bonne image de la france à
l'international parce que ces mouvements
là sont peuvent être également repris
donc il faudrait que nous apprenions
collectivement est un peu plus dans la
discussion dans la concertation
ce que vendait au départ la macro ni si
je puis dire aujourd'hui on a encore une
fois dans des oppositions et je trouve
dommage qu'on rate une telle une telle
opportunité
même si la réforme et d'une manière
générale nécessaire en ce qui concerne
nos retraites et puis on peut ajouter
que là pour le coup les français sont
pas pris en traître puisqu'elle avait
été annoncée dans le programme
présidentiel d'emmanuel macron le dit
emmanuel macron s'est un peu éloigné de
ce remaniement qui s'annonce de cet
agenda social chargé il s'est envolé
pour erevan en arménie pour un sommet de
la francophonie qui réuni 84 états et
gouvernements parce que par exemple il
ya des pays où il ya à la fois le pays
il des gouvernements régionaux comme
celui de wallonie par exemple qu'ils
sont
représenter ça va durer deux jours ce
sommet alors il ya un thème consensuel
en diable ça s'appelle vivre ensemble
dans la solidarité je ne sais plus très
bien quoi est ce que c'est encore à
quelque chose la francophonie
aujourd'hui à part à ceux à se réunir et
à faire des grands discours vincent du
jeu d'abord j'observe que emmanuel
macron éprouvent moins de difficultés à
remanier la tête de la francophonie et
de l'onef que son gouvernement alors ça
on va y venir après fait-il changement
éventuel de patron
où on verra d'ailleurs qu' il y à leur
diktat français qui est un peu
paradoxale passons mais pour un moment
la francophonie suscite en général des
proclamations tout à fait louable moi
j'aime beaucoup cette novlangue andy les
pays qui ont le français en partage
amen j'observe aussi que vous avez des
association un peu insolite là on va
discuter par exemple d'un statut de
membres associés et observateurs pour
l'arabie saoudite
j'aimerais savoir quel est le
pourcentage de saoudiens qui pratiquent
la langue française on a vu passer le
qatar pour des raisons qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec la langue de
molière
en fait c'est retire donc il ya une
vraie difficulté à redéfinir une
francophonie moderne
alors on nous dit dans l'entourage de
manuel macron oui approche décrispé et
c'est ce que veut pas dire grand chose
et puis il ya un autre souci c'est que
sous l'ex président sénégalais abdou
diouf qui a accompli trois mandats à la
tête de l'eau y est fabien et
fraternelle de la francophonie il y a eu
la fichage d'une volonté politique au
sens d'être aussi un instrument de
démocratie agissante
or là dessus franchement il ya encore
des progrès à faire par exemple je cite
que ce cas à ce stade j'ai croisé il ya
quelques jours un député français qui
est membre de la mission d'observation
de l'osce f pour les élections du
cameroun qui était effectivement et
selon une tradition tenace une mascarade
dimanche dernier quand il vous explique
dans quelles conditions il a été
sollicité former ou plutôt pas fort mais
sa date d'arrivée sa date de départ vous
dit attendez si on a un message
francophone spécifiques en termes de
maturité politique et démocratique
il fallait s'y prendre autrement donc il
ya vraiment un lien réel flottement là
dessus donc vous n'avez pas l'air
convaincu de l'utilité de ce de ce
dispositif frédéric saint clair vous non
plus de bien vous trouvez ça bien la
francophonie avant on disait ça permet à
la france d'être influente
aujourd'hui on dit plus à du tout pour
les raison assez simple c'est qu'en
réalité les canaux du soft power passe
par beaucoup d'autres
instrument j'allais dire aux tic que
celui de la langue aujourd'hui 10 soft
power on dit pas pouvoir
d'ailleurs même la traduction c'est une
puissance douce je pensais les mauvaises
donc traduction française puis on souple
c'est un vrai plus adapté donc le la
francophonie à l'époque où la france
avait vocation à devenir un empire était
absolument essentiel parce que de
partager une langue ça permet d'adhérer
un socle de valeurs communes aujourd'hui
c'est absolument pas le cas
on est même al'inverse de ça dans le
respect des cultures indigènes à la fois
à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur des
frontières nationales
donc on dit j'allais dire à l'opposé de
ce qu'a pu être la france jusqu'au début
du 20e siècle
je vois mal aujourd'hui la francophonie
comme un outil permettant de
contrebalancer la domination de
l'anglais comme langue internationale
s'est absolument pas crédible non plus
donc oui pour l'entretenir si ça permet
d'entretenir des liens amicaux et de
resserrer pourquoi pas les intérêts
entre pays j'y crois honnêtement assez
peu après dévoue damien le guay vous y
croyez est-ce que l'avenir de quand même
c'est le français est l'une des langues
les plus parlées dans le monde c'est un
motif de fierté non de fierté
gigantesque et le fait de pouvoir
proposer ce qui était le cas
effectivement des des empires de pouvoir
proposer comme ça le français comme une
commune longue durée ference c nous
sommes aussi une ambition absolument
gigantesque est génial le ce problème me
semble t'il quand tu reviens un peu le
sujet c'est que ça a été mêlé avec des
problèmes politiques
on a voulu faire de la francophonie
quelque chose de politique comme si
derrière la langue
il y avait aussi des valeurs politiques
communes et donc tout là toute la sauce
du
bien vivre ensemble du partage des
droits de l'homme quittera effectivement
on est dit que en afrique ou ailleurs
chacun se débrouille avec sa culture ou
ses habitudes politiques propres mais
qu'on ne partage pas des valeurs qui
sont communes donc le fait d'avoir
mélangé tout à peut-être et mon avis
certainement diminuer la vocation
première de la francophonie à savoir
développer des instituts donner des
moyens les budgets tous ces éléments là
qui permettent de faire la promotion de
la langue et malheureusement on force
est de constater que ses moyens
financiers là sont en diminution
constante et que nous n'avons pas les
moyens de notre ambition et les moyens
qui devraient normalement revenir à la
promotion de la langue parce que tous
ces moyens là diminue donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que si les français ou si la france
défend d elle même ne serait ce que dans
notre façon de parler un respect
scrupuleux de la langue et en évitant de
se faire francs frang lisez francs
globalisé d'accepter comme cela en
permanence dans le discours public dans
à la télévision tous et toutes tous ces
mots anglais qui n'ont rien à faire ici
peut-être qu'on aurait une meilleure
idée de ce qu'est la francophonie et de
la promotion de la langue française qui
est effectivement on peut le dire parce
que nous partageons tous là la plus
belle langue du monde
leila aichi c'est une question de moyens
comme le comme le disait damien le guay
aussi de faire vivre la francophonie oui
évidemment significativement c'est une
question de moyens une question si tu
m'as vraiment d'argent c'est une
question de volonté politique j'aurais
pas un constat aussi aussi négatifs dont
contraire moi je trouve que c'est que
c'est utile c'est un outil pour la
diplomatie du soft power certes il ya
quand même plus de 230 millions
d'individus sur la terre dont sur la
planète qui parlent le français d'ici
2050 on en aura 770 millions je n'ai pas
non plus cette vision catastrophique et
est négative une langue à la vocation à
vivre donc à subir les influences du
monde extérieur toutes les langues se
sont construites de cette manière hier
aujourd'hui
et demain et c'est
je pense également contrairement ce
qu'il a pu être dit autour de cette
table
moi je reste à penser que
l'apprentissage le fait que beaucoup de
peuples dans le monde parle le français
c'est aussi un bien est un vecteur de
véhiculer notre culture quand on apprend
une langue on n'apprend pas simplement
un moyen de communiquer on apprend aussi
ses valeurs son histoire sa culture et
sa une influence évidemment certaines et
si je venais enfin si on peut on pousser
le raisonnement jusqu'au bout
si on venait à fermer enfin aérien fermé
le la francophonie à faire en sorte que
ça n'existe plus quelle serait notre
levier de de commandes ird influence et
je pense que justement face aline
l'omniprésence de l'anglais du fait que
la totalité des pays du monde parle
anglais au détriment du français fait
que justement c'est un outil qui mérite
effectivement d'être améliorée pour
plusieurs raison critique mon manque de
moyens peut-être un manque d'ambition
réel aussi il n'y a pas de volonté
c'est un levier à mon avis n'est pas
suffisamment exploité la francophonie il
ya vous aviez une 1 comment dire une
vision négative que l'arabie saoudite ou
d'autres pays frappent à la porte qui
veulent apprendre le français pourquoi
pas why not je sais pas si vous avez
suivi le cas par exemple de bahreïn à à
bahreïn en fait ils ont
sont d'ailleurs mon fils influence de
l'ancien ambassadeur qui était très
francophone avec une épouse parfaitement
francophone ont influencé de sorte que
les enfants à bahreïn je sais pas si
vous le savez apprennent le français
obligatoirement à l'école primaire mais
moi je trouve ça génial c'est un jeu
c'est un sessad et entre c'est un j'ai
pas dit que c'était c'était bien mais
c'est un jeu d'influencés on ferme la
porte on ferme la porte à notre culture
à nos valeurs et à ce que justement on
veut porter donc je dis pas forcément
l'arabie saoudite est pas un pays
francophone nous sommes d'accord ce
poste a rappelé question de la démission
et je ne fais pas partie de la
francophonie par exemple oui alors pour
le coup évidemment non mais je pense
qu'il faire la part des choses entre une
sorte d'esthétique élitaire de
l'aristocratie locale pour qui ça reste
quand même très chic alexandrie ou
ailleurs dans les six enfants dans une
école francophone et ce qu'est la
véritable existence au quotidien de
cette langue et cette culture dans une
population civile et pour nuancer quand
même un peu le tableau ce qui est vrai
et ça je tiens à le souligner c'est que
j'ai rencontrés dix fois cent fois un
jeune congolais à kinshasa une jeune
irakienne à bagdad pour qui l'alliance
française
le centre culturel français la pratique
de la langue était un véritable espace
de liberté liberté sociale liberté
politique donc je serai le dernier à
nier cette réalité mais le problème
c'est pas ça c'est que précisément en ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui la tendance pour
des raisons éminemment budgétaire si on
a plutôt tendance à supprimer des postes
et à fermer des élèves français les
centres culturels donc que la
francophonie comme idéal porteur de
valeurs soit à coups de sommet au
pinacle très bien mais ce qui est plus
important me semble-t-il c'est cette
francophonie du quotidien mois avec
notamment l'alliance française
on vous a posé la question sur twitter
un selon vous la francophonie at elle un
avenir et vous êtes 59% à nous répondre
oui quelques commentaires à l'aïs qui
nous dit tant qu'on continuera de parler
cette langue française la francophonie
aura toujours de beaux jours devant elle
olympe e livre son témoignage pour bien
connaître la situation du français au
canada
cette langue est malmené au québec est
double béquille nous dit on ne fait
croire à travers la francophonie que
nous sommes encore une grande nation
alors que nous ne le sommes plus depuis
bien longtemps
vraiment effectivement on essaie de
répondre à cette question encore un mot
là-dessus le ce sommet est aussi
l'occasion
d'une nouvelle élection à la tête de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
il ya une secrétaire générale sortante
qui s'appelle michaëlle jean qui est
haïtienne sauf erreur de ma part qui se
représentent
voilà il ya un canadien d'origine
haïtienne merci de le préciser
et puis il ya une autre candidate qui
est la ministre des affaires étrangères
du rwanda qui semble-t-il est soutenue
par la france
on va éclaircir ça après en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça déplaît
profondément à marine le pen écoutez là
c'est la décision d' emmanuel macron
semble-t-il de soutenir à la tête de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
une ministre de kagamé violemment
antifrançaises violemment antifrançaises
qui explique qu'il faut pas parler
français qu' il faut parler anglais que
ça amène beaucoup plus loin que le
français kagame qui a fait je vous
rappelle raser le centre culturel
français à kigali à 4 ans kamel
président rwandais est ce que cette
accusation est légitime et justifiée
vincent un jeu outrancière comme
d'habitude s'agissant de l'oratrice
convient d'écouter n'en revenons
simplement la vérité des faits
l'engagement français auprès de louise
mushikiwabo donc ministre des affaires
étrangères infiniment loyal à paul
kagame a quelque chose de profondément
baroque
pourquoi parce que le 23 mai dernier
paul kagame sur le perron de l'elysée
annoncé promeut cette candidature dans
la langue de shakespeare
bon forcément ravir les au rwanda la
langue officielle c'est l'angle j'ajoute
que depuis 2009 la langue prioritaires
d'enseignement à partir du primaire
n'est plus le français mais et l'anglais
et c'est évidemment là encore une
posture qui est intégralement politique
et qui renvoie au caractère exécrable de
la relation bilatérale notamment depuis
le génocide de 1994 au passage on
soulignera que paris n'a pas jugé utile
d'envoyer un ambassadeur à kigali
aujourd'hui simplement quand vous
objecter cela à l'entourage
macron on vous dit mais il ne s'agit pas
d'une relation bilatérale il s'agit de
quelqu'un qui est opérationnel qui a
l'expérience qui associe qui à cela mais
quand même il est tout à fait légitime
de prétendre que l'avenir de la
francophonie se joue aussi en afrique
très bien que donc le poste pourquoi pas
il était occupé par l'égyptien boutros
boutros ghali puis par le sénégalais
abdou diouf peut ou doit revenir à un
africain en afrique n pourquoi pas mais
franchement l'afrique n'a pas d'autre
candidat à proposer que quelqu'un qui a
porté une parole de citer alors ayant
dit cela je ne peux pas être suspect de
complaisance pour l'ancien régime rang
des gt1 des gens et de france et
d'ailleurs à quelques confrères du
figaro qui ont été les plus offensifs
sur la responsabilité historique
ne serait ce que par cette cécité
volontaire de la france dans le génocide
de 94 donc c'est pas le problème
c'est simplement que le message qui est
convoyée par ce soutien
j'ajoute le lâchage dans les grandes
largeurs sans qu'on ait venir m'en
compris quels sont les griefs adressés à
la sortante
il ya quand même quelque chose là qui
est tout à fait insolite et bien voilà
un point éclairci il nous reste quelques
minutes pour parler d'une information
révélée ce matin par nos confrères du
canard enchaîné le patron de force
ouvrière pascal pavageau qui était en
campagne avait quand il était en
campagne pardon pour succéder à
jean-claude mailly avait mis en fiches
en tout cas si ce n'est lui c'est son
équipe de collaborateurs plus de 100
cadres de force ouvrière avec des fiches
extrêmement précises avec la photo le
numéro de téléphone portable mais
surtout des mentions assez précises
genre anarchiste francs-maçons ce qui
prouve qu'on ne l'est pas forcément
quand on est à force ouvrière plus de
mythos christ
voilà plutôt à droite bête j'espère que
ça va pas forcément ensemble ordures
aussi ça c'est moi c'est moins agréable
il dit qu'il est désolé mais qu' il
semble ne semble pas pour autant décidé
à démissionner frédéric saint clair si
ça arrivait dans une entreprise le
directeur des ressources humaines
probablement garderait pas son poste
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il s'en aille le
patron de force ouvrière il faut je n'en
sais rien s'il faut qu'il s'en aille
je moi ce que je suis rarement choqué
par la morale de lâches
on trouve quelqu'un bête
voire pire c'est son droit
moi je suis en règle générale choqué par
l'intelligence du propos ou son manque
d'intelligence je ne comprends pas
comment il est possible de faire des
fiches pour mettre des informations
aussi niaise que celle là j'arrive pas à
me défendre l'intelligence du propos qui
allaient vous n'êtes pas choquer
forcément vous dit c'est pas mal hein
mais c'est pas mal je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de se poser la question morale
de macron n'a fait que ça il nous il
nous a rebattu les oreilles avec sa
moralisation
ça ne sert à rien ça n'aide pas à la
décision politique je dis juste que
quand on est directeur d'un syndicat on
a des questions à leur poser et les
questions ne doivent pas à mon avis
rentrer dans ce cadre-là ce qu'une
personne est une ordure ou pas une
ordure
est ce qu'un jugement personnel est pas
suffisant il faut 2 m en fiche mais
aussi des éléments concrets est ce qui
nous soutient est ce qui nous soutient
pas damien le guay est ce qu'il faut en
finir avec la morale forcément pas
forcément forcément que la morale est
une chose importante
la seule chose c'est que je me méfie
toujours depuis parce qu'on en a parlé
juste avant mais depuis la sphère fillon
je ne me fie toujours de l'information
d'où ça vient qui a intérêt à ce que ça
se sache qui il a regagné 1
je ne suis pas contre un avec qui a
intérêt qui intéresse que peuvent un
jour soit d'une façon ou d'une autre d
un geek ce temps est donc je pense que
que le premier travail des journalistes
je peux me permettre d'en donner parce
que ça n'a pas été fait effectivement au
moment de la sphère fillon c'est de
savoir d'où ça vient qui a balancé ça et
pourquoi parce que l'un qui lui faisait
mal évidemment
forcément je crois c'est vrai c'est
quand même grave ça c'est drôle mais
points le deuxième point c'est que alors
ça dépend de la nature des fiches si
vous voulez des fiches personnelles que
l'on fait sur par soi-même pour soi-même
pour mieux comprendre sa mémoire est un
peu défaillante qui équipe par rapport à
qui je ne sais pas quel point troisième
point moi je me souviens quand même du
mur des cons qui était effectivement
dans le syndicat majoritaire de la
magistrature il me semble pas que tout
ça est supposé morale ou pas moral je ne
sais pas mais que tout cela est supposé
quelques
quelques démissions en cascade des uns
et des autres et est donc est donc
peut-être effectivement quelque chose
sur la classification ou sur les
relations amis ennemis au sein d'un
syndicat ou par rapport à l'extérieur
c'est des choses qui semble t-il relaté
une procédure judiciaire en cours 1 pour
le syndicat de la magistrature avec un
projet qui devrait bientôt arriver
vincent est ce que ça vous a choqué donc
ça ce sont les arriérés de l'extrême
virulence de la guérilla très peu
urbaine entre le sortant jean claude
mallet son successeur j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que dans les documents en
question qui ne sont pas contestés en
termes de densité
il est dédié sous ses initiales pp ce
qui nous renvoie à la préfecture de
police dans l'histoire de flint cage ça
me paraît assez cohérent et pépé comme
pascal pavageau pour sa part au dernier
point c'est que dans les réponses
générales un peu pauvre qu ils objectent
aucun d'enchaîner il dit ceci je le cite
il ne s'agit que d'un document de
travail qui ne devait pas circuler donc
il ne remet pas en question la substance
l'essence du document mais le fait que
c'était un document de travail de quel
type de travail s'agit-il
franchement et que simplement son défaut
c'est qu'il ne devait pas circuler
accord mais quand même assez grotesque
comme des fausses on vous a posé la
question à sur twitter selon vous pascal
pavageau doit-il démissionner vous
répondez oui à 75% et misto fort ajoute
et certains s'étonnent que les syndicats
soient boudées par les salariés leila
ici est ce que vous êtes d'accord ce
point de vue en fait le ski est nul
c'est de s'être fait prendre
mais finalement ça tout le monde tout le
monde peut-être fait des faits d'aidé
des fiches pour se renseigner sur ses
collaborateurs ou alors on se dit les
choses donc pourquoi ne pas les écrire
c'est pas un peu hypocrite tout ça ce
n'est pas qu'une question de
l'hypocrisie effectivement je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faille pas
aller sur
logique mort à la morale etc c'est ce
qui ce que le syndicat a fait
accessoirement quand même il légal en
vérité nous n'avons pas le droit de
ficher les gens en fonction de deux
critères en plus à vocation
professionnelle ils sont 126 on les
cibles en fonction alors on collait nord
leur nom leur position éventuellement
politique proche ou pas c'est juste
illégal alors évidemment la morale c'est
un sujet c'est ainsi qu'ils sont
homosexuels c'est un sujet on n'a pas le
droit dans notre pays de faire des
fiches qui classe les gens en fonction
de leur orientation sexuelle orientation
politique c'est totalement illégal donc
on est encore je crois dans un état de
droit alors doit-il ou pas démissionner
la décision personnellement ne
m'appartient pas il doit répondre de ses
actes il est responsable dirigeants de
son syndicat il doit être responsable de
ces de ses subordonnés et donc la
justice je fais confiance en notre
justice qui sera à prendre les décisions
utiles pour le coup personnellement je
trouve ce type de fichage au delà du
fait que c'est d'un mauvais goût plus
que limité borderline puisque on est
vraiment dans l'illégalité absolue et
c'est typiquement ce genre de fichier
qui quand on commence à réfléchir un peu
plus longuement et de façon plus
lointaines qui peuvent se révéler
extrêmement dangereux qu'est ce qu'ils
font de ce type de fichier et les
vendent ils transmettent qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont formé les utilisent pour quoi
faire
pour la campagne électorale parce qu'il
est mon sens vous imaginez ont ils
peuvent avant si on autorise ce type de
comment dire de comportement on peut
continuer aussi à classer les gens en
fonction de l'heure où pas mal a dit ça
finit donc afficher enfin moi ce système
de fichage me gêne beaucoup voilà donc
c'est illégal
on doit s'inscrire en faux contre ce
type de process
on est dans l'époque c'est que ça choque
probable moi j'ai ce titre et en même
temps sur facebook les gens se révèlent
comme ils n'ont jamais fait se mettre
quasiment à nu d'une part mais s'ils
voulaient enfin si on élargit un tout
petit peu la question là le fait d'avoir
des informations personnelles sur les
gens nous rentrons dans un monde qui est
celui de de l'assurance de la banque par
le numérique et par l'intelligence
artificielle qui va de plus en plus
ficher les gens
et alors c'est pas forcément bien non
plus il ya des risques
il ya des risques évidents inhérents aux
systèmes corp nous sommes à court terme
parce que ça se fait que c'est bien sauf
d'accord t'es un jugement moral qu'il
faut avoir
donc le jugement moral là dessus c'est
de dire que moi je suis
pas pour le défendre particulièrement je
dis simplement que le grand risque que
nous avons sur ces questions de fish
s'est effectivement que le monde de
demain
celui qui va arriver c'est celui où
toutes les caractéristiques personnelles
des individus sont pas anonymes mais
seront précises sur le poids la taille
le risque les antécédents et que donc de
plus en plus on va avoir une forme de
deux contraintes des individus pour
accéder au crédit pour accéder pour
accéder aux assurances pour et c'est sur
ces critères il me semble que ce
problème là est beaucoup plus important
malheureusement un peu oublié que celui
là qui est peut-être secondaire et qui
n'est pas secondaire il vise
l'orientation sexuelle d'une personne
dans ce dans le fichier c'est pas normal
qu'un seul un employeur en employeur
qu'elle quelle que soit l'organisation
n'a pas affiché ses salariés ou ses
adhérents en fonction de critères et de
discriminant donc il faut en plus un
syndicat qui est 110 ans et marié qui
déforme de salariés qui ont des sens et
qui descend qui défend par hamon qui est
censé quand même donné défendre les
salariés qui est hyper capable de
l'appliquer à lui-même enfin bon c'est
en termes pas moi je trouve ça
lamentable
si les syndicats défendent et des
salariés cela sort ça serait pas contre
un départ avant tout kadhafi ces
derniers ces sanitaires vont présenter
quelqu'un ça se saurait depuis longtemps
de voir la passion de personnes donc
vous ça me paraît plus grave cela que
effectivement le fait savoir si son fils
joue pas mais si c'est si effectivement
ça passera sa passe bientôt devant les
tribunaux on verra bien voilà merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre pour ces
différents points de vue l'émission
revient demain à la même heure et au
même endroit
merci beaucoup bonsoir
[Musique]